انت كنت البنايه سقطت وعشتي كل المشهد
وبقيتي تحت الانقاض صحيح ممكن تحكي لنا
القصه الحكايه من اللحظه الاولى كيف لما
بدا الزلزال ولحين ان خرجتي اول شيء كنا
نايمين الصحه ابناء اعطيته الجوال شوي
لانه ابني كان مريض حسينا يعني بشاعه
بيتحرك قلت معقول انا فينا ضغط شوي قلت
معقول ضغطي عم يلعب فيا متسطحه هيك حسيت
لانه قبل بمره صار هزي انا كتير برتعب قلت
لهم
البنات طالعت ابني ركض ركيد طالعنا كان
مطر كتير كتير مطر صار فجاه ياخد من البيت
هيك ويجيبنا هيك ياخذنا هيك ويجيبنا هيك
بعدها صار مثل الجرس يلعب فينا هل صحيح
كان في صوت قوي صاحب الزلزال كان صوت كاني
عم السيخين حديده عم تضربن في بعض كاني عم
جرس المدرسه على شكل جرس المدرسه اول شيء
صار اخدنا هيك وجابنا هيك وبعدها صار
يخطنا خط البيت بس بدي اركض طالع الاولاد
اول شيء طلعنا مطر كلياتنا طلعنا فتت قلت
اسا عم نطلع نحنا وعم ينزل علينا هاد ارضي
الرماد ايه انا قويت قلبي لانه ابني مانو
لابس مشان ما يمرض لانه مريض اجيب له
الجاكيت طب علينا
كلياتنا طالع عم بقلع عم قلك خلي اسحبيهم
لغاد يعني ما توقعنا انه تنهد علينا
لهالدرجه يعني قبل بمره صاير زلازل بس ما
توقعنا لهالدرجه خرجتي في البدايه ومن ثم
لتجري بملابس استمر الباب ما طلعت قلت له
للاولاد فت اجيب الجاكيت طبت البنايه انت
وحدك
يعني انت انت الوحيده اللي كنت تحت
الانقاذ كافيه كتير
طابق وانه راحوا وما في اتصالات وهنا
فكروني طلعت انا وانه بعدوا يعني موقف
كتير صعب يعني لهلق ببرك وقعد بصرخي بقلم
الارض عم بتهز الارض عم بتهز اي لهلا